if no one else is gonna speak on it then
I guess it's my duty to say it
Rachel Lindsay wants The Bachelor
franchise to make some big changes I
just want to thank you guys so much for
being here I've had such a great time
getting to talk to each and every one of
you the former Bachelorette who remains
the franchise's only black lead to date
said during a recent interview with
afterbuzz that she would cut ties with a
hit ABC show if they don't make some
major changes to address their lack of
diversity and representation so I think
that they have to at this point
give us a black pastor for season 25 you
have to I don't know how you don't and
it's been asked of me while I continue
in this franchise if it continues in
this way I can't I have to see some type
of change it's ridiculous it's
embarrassing if this one it's
embarrassing to be affiliated with it
Rachel took things a step further on
Monday explaining on her blog why the
ABC franchise needs a diversity makeover
adding that after being a part of the
bachelor family for almost four years we
still don't have the diversity that this
show needs and that our audience
deserves I'm honored to be the first
Rachel who became the first black
Bachelorette back in 2017 says that
she's always been vocal about this issue
but adds I still feel that I have not
been loud enough on the deep rooted
eighteen-year systemic problems in this
franchise adding that she's tired of her
effort being ineffective we need to
change the system something has to be
done break the rules step outside the
box give the people what they want last
year when Peter Weber was passed as the
bachelor over fan favorite Mike Johnson
who would have been the first black
bachelor Rachel admitted to et that she
was disappointed I think Peter seems
like a very nice guy he seems lovely
this is absolutely nothing against him
but how many peers have we seen before
what season are we on mm 24 so we've
seen 24 Peter's okay I'm bored okay it
is nothing personal against him I'm sure
it'll turn out to be a great season but
for the first time I was very confident
that we were going to see our first
black bachelor and so if no one
is gonna speak on it then I guess it's
my duty to say it I mean I want to be
hopeful but when you have a contestant
like Mike Johnson and who seems to check
all the boxes how is he not the bachelor
I don't understand what I will say is I
am sure they have some reason for not
picking him and I'm going to trust in
that but at the same time the system
isn't working and giving us a bachelor
who's a person of color now rachel is
calling for a few changes including
casting leads that are interested in
dating outside of their race and
diversifying producers on the show and
she says the franchise should make a
statement acknowledging their systemic
racism et has reached out to Warner
Brothers and ABC for comment
Rachel wrapped up her message writing
only time will tell how the franchise
will respond but to date they have been
silent until then make sure you tune in
on Mondays for all the white reasons to
watch The Bachelor greatest seasons ever
as it will weekly highlight the very
thing that is wrong with this franchise
[Music]